Passwords are not really random.
So when somebody's trying
a brute force attack.
They don't have to sort of search for
things in the dark.
What they really, if they're smart, they
would start with more popular passwords.
So the 12345 or password or
whatever it is.
So you absolutely can sort of reduce
the amount of work that you have to do
by trying out more
popular passwords first.
In fact, what you can do is create
what is called a rainbow table,
which is nothing but potential
passwords and their hash values and
as a table that you create.
The hashed value table for each possible
password and so this is, you don't even
have to run your hash function when
you're doing this brute force guessing.
You're just doing a lookup in
a rainbow table saying this password
let me see what it's corresponding
hash value is and does that match
some entry in the rainbow table without
having to compute the hash function.
You can have these other tricks you can
use if that hacker is use you rainbow
table or be smart and
try more popular passwords first.
The couple of other things related
to passwords and their guessing and
things like that, we said, what if
two users pick the same password?
If you have common passwords,
then of course 12345 is taken
by lots and lots of users.
How do we avoid this problem?
In one of the quiz questions we say,
what would happen if
the hash value is the same.
It's sort of related here.
If they do have the same password,
they'll have the same hash value.
And by looking at the hash values,
we can see that from one person's
password we can login as the other
user and that would be a problem.
Fortunately, we have a solution to that,
we add a random number
before we do the hashing.
We take the password strength,
add this random salt.
The random salt will be different for
different users, that makes the hash
value different for different users.
If two users pick the same password,
without the salt, the hash value
will be the same, but with the salt,
the hash value will be different.
And we will know whether
the passwords are the same or
they're different because the hash
values could be different,
either because of the passwords being
different or the salt being different.
You'll have to store the salt because
later on when we do the check,
we're going to get a password.
We'll need the salt before
we can run the hash again.
So we can compare it
with the hashed value.
So we're going to need the salt.
Where do you store the salt?
You store it in the file where
you store the hashed value.
Whoever has access to the hashed value
would also have access to the salt,
which is fine.
Actually not a problem.
So this checking, when we have salt,
is done by combining or
computing the hash function with
both the salt and the password.